my name is Aviv and I'm going to be
teaching you today what we're gonna do
today is we're gonna show I'm gonna show
you a chess game one of my favourite
game to show to my students and it was
played by one of the best American
players of all time
maybe the first first best American in
the world and his name is Paul Morphy
how many of you have heard of Paul
Morphy before some of you very good Paul
Morphy was really a fantastic chess
player in the 19th century he was so
good at one point that they couldn't
find him any opponents in America he was
just beating everybody so they decided
to send him to Europe to the continent
of Europe to play matches against the
best players there and guess what he
beat them too so he was unofficially the
first maybe world's champion the best
player in the world at the time and he
was a very very talented player and he
was also a very aggressive player what
I'm hoping that you guys are gonna pick
up from this game is not exactly moved
for move what he played or how he did it
but I want you to get an idea of how
great it is when you play aggressive
chess when you're really trying to
attack your opponent try to look for his
weaknesses try to take all these pieces
and check making if to speak in a simple
way
and in this what's really beautiful
about this game and in my opinion also
amazing is that he played this game not
in a tournament competition not like
one-on-one when they just play the
regular chess game they play this in a
simultaneous exhibition you know what a
simultaneous is how many new you have
heard of it before some of you know this
is when one player is playing a bunch of
other players they're taking their seats
and one person is he is going and making
moves on every board and then they make
their moves and then he makes another
move okay so many chess masters and
grandmasters can do that that's normal
but what's especially amazing about this
game is that Paul Morphy did not look at
the board that was a blindfold
simultaneous exhibition so imagine
you're playing your opponent and you're
not looking at the board at
and you're not just playing one opponent
you're playing several opponents that is
a very hard task I mean if you close
your eyes and we play the chess games
chess chess game I will bet you that
after a few moves you're gonna tell me
wait Ivey I'm confused what is the
position and even for me it's not that
easy
some people are better than others but
he was great at that so now he's playing
a serious club player someone who has
you know pretty decent rating and he's
playing to play someone like Murphy and
he Murphy is not looking at the board
and look at the kind of game he plays
when you think that he never looked at
the board he just had to play this
without looking that's very impressive
so the game was played many years ago in
1859 is the year in London and his
opponents name is James Cunningham
that's not so important now everybody
look at the game and let's try to learn
so ofor of course we know Ponto at the
center that's something we're familiar
with Andy five at that time that was
almost the only opening after a four to
play e5 before white gets to play d4 for
free so now Murphy knows and he played
many times different things before we
know that we can develop the knight to
f3 Knight c3 and play different
variations also the King's gambit all
kinds of crazy gambit and here Paul
Morphy plays Bishop c4 he doesn't commit
any of his Knights for now he develops
his bishop towards the center a very
normal opening he plays the move pawn to
c3 in case you guys are wondering why
this move I'm sure that when a second
look when you take a second look you
understand Paul Morphy is ready to play
the move d4 hitting the center
immediately so his opponent said I don't
really like that I don't feel like
you're attacking the bishop so quickly
so he played the move Knight to c6 again
so far both players are playing a
perfectly fine game black is developing
controlling the center developing his
minor pieces towards the center just
like the book says just like we're
supposed to do so more if he played
Knight f3 again the same thing Knight
towards the center now we see the black
cannot stop the move d4 after all and
the question is how is he going to be
ready for it because when white plays
the move d4 he gains a tempo over the
bishop his
so attacking the pawn on e5 twice and
he's got to be ready for it so he plays
probably the best move even nowadays so
many years later this is still the best
move Knight to f6 very good so far the
game is perfect really can't complain
so of course more if he plays d4 as
expected and he's kinda it's kind of a
fork because he's attacking the bishop
and the pawn at the same time so black
must take and now we know that there are
two ways to play it one of them is to
take immediately with the pawn and
attack the bishop and the bishop will be
very very smart if he gave the check
once the pawn captured the C pawn took
on d4 he will play Chuck and that's a
completely different variation a
different line it can also be very very
wild there's all kinds of ideas can
sacrifice material but in this game more
if he simply continues by saving his
e-pawn and pushing it to the center to
attack the knight okay very very good
again maybe his opponent was a little
confused because at that time maybe it
was not a normal opening for him and his
answer wasn't that good I can tell you
that the best answer is to play the move
d5 and basically say okay you're
attacking my knight if I just move my
knight you might take the pawn and
everything is protected you have a
strong center I don't feel like doing
that I don't feel like just moving my
knight so you're attacking my knight I'm
going to attack your bishop that's how
I'm gonna do it and again I don't want
to go too much far away from the game I
can just mention the best line white
doesn't want to give up his good Bishop
here so he will move it to b5 and then
black goes Knight to the center a very
good place I mean the knight was a fact
we were about to capture a night the
knight saves itself and now this is just
a normal game white will get his pawn
back and the bishop will move okay
all this is not new but just a different
variation in the game he was probably a
little bit in panic because he said wow
what's going to happen he's about to
take my knight in any Knight move he's
just gonna take the pawn back and I have
a terrible position
so he said okay I have a great move for
me I'm gonna play Queenie 7 now I can
tell you that this is already the first
step in the wrong direction
cause you don't want to develop your
queen too early especially than e45
opening like this and when you look at
you say wow Aviv how can this be bad
he is pinning the pawn to the king can
we play pawn takes Knight no it's it's
pinned yeah so we can't do that don't be
too mad at me so we can't do that
obviously and in the meantime it looks
like the Black Knight is also attacking
the pawn so now black has to attack is
the knight and the Queen white is only
one defender which is the knight so it
looks that Hawking this move be bad but
this is a really poor place for the
Queen and you will see that with White's
next move Black is getting into trouble
I will play the movement let's try to
discuss it castles very nice that is a
very very good move well what is the
point of this move it looks like we're
not only lost one pawn that we
sacrificed but now it looks like there's
a second point in the center how many do
you think that black should just take
that pawn get rid of the attack on his
knight just take it how do you think we
should do that I don't see many hands
and for a good reason
who could tell me why it would be a
really bad idea
for black to take this pawn on e5 yes
that's right you can see that the e-file
is open one side is already cancelled
the other one is not in positions like
this the uncounseled king should be
really careful of any surprises from the
e-file and if he wants to open it then
thank you very much that'll be just what
the white doctor ordered as they say and
now the king and the queen are lined up
beautifully on the e-file all we need to
do is swing our rook do you think this
is going to be good for the black player
not very appetizing no okay okay back we
go so we have castle so now black must
have been already a bit unhappy because
his knight is attacked he was hoping to
take the pawn he pinned it to the king
why just ran away with his king there
was no more payment the threat remained
and he didn't know what to do he decided
to play Knight to g8 already we can
smile because well it's very nice when
the opponent makes a move like this and
he undeveloped the knight then we know
we must have done something wrong and he
did something very badly but let's see
could he have played something else
let's try something like Knight to g4
and move that kind of keeps the knight
on the board like active well in this
case white would have just said okay let
me take my pawn back and attack the
bishop
and let's say that the bishop would have
just saved itself because we don't want
to give up the bishop and now White has
several pleasant choices one of them he
can kick the knight because the poor
Knight has exactly one move to go to and
that's to the rim right there and have
you ever heard of the expression that
knight on a rim is de more grim right
whatever makes that make the rhyme
so now white can continue with Knight to
c3 already the knight is coming to this
very strong d5 square and if you look at
the position you can tell that white has
an enormous advantage really a huge huge
advantage really a black is in trouble
so he was unhappy with that but what he
the solution that he found in the game I
can tell you was also not a very good
solution
so Knight the g8 okay now once again
it's our turn what should we do let's
hear if any of you
have ideas of what will be our next move
so far we're kind of happy with the how
the way things have developed we managed
to control the center well develop minor
pieces our king is already canceled the
blocking is not only that it's not
canceled but it's stuck on a 8 and the
night coming back to g8 is in his way
it's going to take him at least two
moves two good moves to castle so what
should we do is white if we just fall
asleep and do nothing then black is
going to get organized and then we have
not much so yes very interesting a very
exciting move Bishop g5 tempo over the
the Queen I like that as well okay
anything else other ideas yes all the
way in the back on d4 yes so first
things first took the pawn back on d4
why not now I have a beautiful Center I
get my pawn my sacrifice pawn back and
I'm attacking the bishop on c5 all at
the same time that cannot possibly be a
bad move okay so black decided to save
his bishop again you can find lots of
good moves this is the kind of position
that it's really hard to find a bad move
for white unless you really try you know
but if you play just by by logic then
all the moves are good if you suggested
like re Bishop g5 here that's a great
move the poor Queen will have to go
somewhere but one thing I have to tell
you is the Queen would be happy only 7
probably not you will much rather have
the disk where empty so I can put my
night from g8 on it so I don't know if I
really want to change the Queen away but
even that is not a bad idea
Knight to c3 is another wonderful idea
trying to jump with a Knight to d5
beautiful move but white played another
choice he just said hey I have all the
space in the world I can gain more space
and more ground and we already know that
when you have lots of space your chances
of winning the game increased by a lot
how many of you already know how to
count for space anybody who was in my
classes when I was here several months
ago probably knows and probably people
read it in the book but how many of you
know not many let me tell you a little
bit about it I always like to divide the
board just down the middle if you see
where my
cursor is going this is for for white
for for black right and now what I do is
any piece that goes beyond that halfway
mark or aims beyond the halfway mark I'm
gonna award at one point so let's check
it out let's see how many squares of
space black has so black has denied is
attacking this pawn is one denied is
attacking this is to the bishop is
attacking the pawn is three the Queen
coming here is four five with the Queen
six with the Queen so six moves in total
right I don't think I missed anything
again we check good moves and bad move
just the control of the pieces doesn't
mean that we have to go there so black
has six squares of space
six points of space now let's check out
white I promise you it's gonna be more
so the pawn is here that's one he's
attacking here that's two three the
bishop four five six seven eight
denied nine the bishop ten and eleven
the pawn here is 12 and did I miss
anything probably not so already white
has doubled the amount of space that
black has and we can get even more space
believe it or not so I can tell you when
you have five points of space advantage
that's already very nice that means you
have an advantage when the space
advantage goes to 10 and above that's
almost always it always always means
that the opponent is lost the side with
the left space is in trouble so what
what why did
d5 beautiful the one good piece that we
had the night is now being kicked and
we're black was thinking about this
position he said wait well I already
know I can take the pawn on e5 that's no
news right that's we already seen that
before no way if I go here there's a
white knight ready to take me if I go
here it's very stranded and it can be
chased away and he said hmm maybe
instead of just moving the night I can
just attack one of my opponent's pieces
and he played a reasonable move he
played a really move considering that
the position is so badly played and
decent move Queen c5 the Queen moves
away from the place the bad spot and he
is attacking the bishop at the same time
now he says okay
if you take my night I'll take your
bishop even trade now how many of you
think that white wants to trade a lot of
pieces in this position nah white says
my pieces are better than your pieces
your pieces are clumsy and there some of
them are back home and my pieces are
aggressive I don't want to trade my good
[ __ ] up for that night so white decided
to simply develop his night I know it's
night on a rim a little bit but the
night is developed for the sake of
developing of defending the bishop on c4
once again the pool knight on c6 is
attacked so he decided I'm gonna go
aggressive if I play passively my
opponent is going to beat me let me play
an aggressive move but I can tell you a
very good hint for your chess game when
you are behind in development when your
pieces are not that active if you try to
be aggressive and active and your
opponent is more prepared chances are
it's not going to turn out well and this
is what happened to black here here
probably his best move would have been
to either go back with the knight or go
Knight a5 try to attack this Bishop
still white will be tremendously better
but it's not gonna be as bad as what
happened in the game in the game he said
okay I want to bring my knight to the
center I want to try to trade pieces
maybe maybe I'll be really lucky maybe
my opponent is gonna be so bad that he's
gonna take the knight and I'll take back
maybe he will trade Queens do you think
that's going to happen here in your
dreams no more free said not today sir
so another question is let's try to be
more for ourselves and let's play simple
chess
let's think what should we do now okay
we can't avoid trading pieces he wants
to trade the Knights we can't avoid that
but I don't want to take because then he
wants to trade Queens - I don't like
that so how do I continue playing
logical chess and I'm looking I don't
see many hands so let me give you a hint
that will guide you to a job I see that
three of my minor pieces are developed
my knight my bishop my other night and
my King is canceled but I see for
example that my bishop on c1 is a minor
piece it's not developed so maybe it's
time to get it into the game with power
how do I do that yes
exactly the bishop comes to the center
pinning the knight well now black has
exactly one move if he doesn't want a
kiss give this Knight goodbye and just
see it get off the board for nothing
then he might as well play the only move
that he has which is Knight takes Knight
we check he has to save his knight and
the only way to save it is by trading it
for the night okay the good news for us
is white now our queen comes into the
game with a tempo and came black now
just continue his development like maybe
develop that silly night on g8 is that a
good time to do that no I don't think so
either not unless you want to give me
your queen for nine points right now for
a bishop so the poor Queen has to make
yet another move but where am I going to
go with this Queen after all you see the
Queen is already looking at this very
weak pawn on f7 and there's a bishop
just waiting to open up for that square
so the white wants to play a move like
d6 so he decided to play Queen to f8 all
the way to f8 why not to e7 because if
you want to played Queen to e7 what do
you think white would have played here I
want to see how many people can figure
out what very attractive move does white
have in this position I can tell he has
more than one good move but one of them
is like I am almost sure I would have
played it yes almost d one more correct
exactly right I would have played b6
more if he would have definitely played
these six all my goodness not only is he
opening up the position attacking the
Queen and the poor Queen can't just go
anywhere because it needs to defend the
pawn on f7 this is just more bad news so
now we understand why he played his
Queen to f8 okay very nice and now again
it's white to move we say to ourself
well our queen is developed all our
miners are developed we have a
tremendous Center the black pieces are
really bad he has basically one piece
developed and all the rest are back home
just like sitting in the bleachers right
spectating the game so now we thought
here is what I'm going to do I'm going
to create a new weakness and I'm going
to
watch what he does step 1 he doubly
trades the only developed black piece
that was actually doing something he
trades it and there are two reasons for
that
a getting rid of it two making a new
weakness when black took now I said I
see a weakness who can spot the weakness
let's see if somebody can look at the
black army and say wow I see a really
weak spot now that I can attack with my
pieces especially one of my pieces
that's not doing a whole lot right now I
can bring it into the game with a bang
all the way in the back tell me that's
exactly what morphe did because what
square is he attacking c7 exactly he's
very hungry looking at the pawn on c7
and when you look at that point all of a
sudden you'll realize wait a minute how
do I even defend it how do I defend it
can I use my maybe look in the corner
right here to defend it well not in this
game sorry so he played again probably
the only move that he had King to d8
what a sad moved to have to make but he
cannot afford to lose it because if I
fork if I my knight gets the to play to
c7 it's gonna be a nice little fork not
only forcing the key to move winning
upon but also getting a good taste of
this rook in the corner so poor block
had to move okay
now White has tons of good moves because
I want to do a little stop very quick
stop for the sake of looking at space
one more time very quickly how many
points of space does black have he has
one would his queen second with his
queen three four and five things to
those moves with the rock so five points
of space now white one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve thirteen fourteen fourteen four
now well remember what I said before
about space advantage no wonder that
white is really doing well so he can
play d6 which is a great move he can
play
Queen to g3 which is a great move Queen
to e3 also a good move with the idea of
d6 he played another developing move
rook a to c1 his rook comes to this
through the half-open file and it's kind
of tickling the pawn on c7 he's kind of
looking at the pawn on c7 maybe now
black should have played c6 but then the
White Knight would have just jumped at a
beautiful d6 square poor black just
suffering the whole game in the game he
said well I have to somehow to get my
pieces out let me develop that Bishop on
c8 and he played these six and what said
okay let's open up the position even
more that's a good deal for me I'm more
ready for it he took and took very good
now the black pawn structure also looks
a little funny and now once again we see
a brand new weakness created who can
show me where is that weakness what new
target can white find in the black army
the black army I'm talking about all
those three ranks where you have black
pieces on nothing is on the fourth rank
for black so all those think of what is
the weakest square that's easy for us to
attack and not that great for the
opponent to defend brown shirt on the
block on the left
correct b6 exactly very poor double pawn
very vulnerable pawn now if you could
use your imagination you look at the
board and I could tell you that this is
like a bughouse game you can take any
one of your pieces and put it on b6
which piece would you like to see on b6
yes Queen absolutely now I can tell you
that it's not going to work out to play
Queen from f3 to b6 even chess base
which is a very nervous machine be quiet
for a second did you hear the chirp that
means that it's illegal can do that so
how can we get the Queen ready to be
jumping to that square you can say it if
you want you have an idea
very good Queen to e3 exactly right
ready to go and black is already
desperate and he plays the only move the
defend square work to a6
not a pretty move to make but hey I have
to defend because if the Queen goes to
be six is the disaster still White has
tons of good moves here he can get his
other rook involved you can do all kinds
of things but he decides to remember
that was an exhibition what does this
mean there was a crowd looking at the
games he was playing a blindfold
simultaneous he has a blindfold like
this he's not looking at the board he's
playing several people and there is a
crowd looking and being impressed by the
game so sometimes when you're playing
with a crowd you want to impress the
crowd right so he played what we say a
move for the crowd 97 that's what we
call a quiet sacrifice he is telling him
here here's a gift from me to you my
horsey take it take my knight it's all
yours well I'm sure you can see that
there is a rook hiding right here with
the bishop between them and after King
takes Knight what would he have played
Bishop takes rook I'm sure everybody
sees that Bishop takes rook we check not
only winning material but also exposing
the King to disaster
well sad position black says okay I have
to lose material plus I'm being attacked
I really don't like that let's at least
try to reduce some of the material let
me play the move Queen seven maybe we
can get to trade Queens then even if I
lose in exchange even if you get to
capture my rook with either uniting your
bishop they'll still be a long fight and
maybe I can still stay alive maybe we
can I can defend some how do you think
most morphic traded Queens here no
instead he played them not a beautiful
move for the crowd he said I have a
great two instead of just moving my
Queen away for example he could have
played the move Queen G 3 and that would
have been a perfect move moving the
Queen away attacking the pawn on g7
ready to bring his rook into the game
and attack the Queen that would have
been perfect but again he's playing with
a crowd watching he wants to impress
them and he plays 96 check brilliant the
knight check interrupts the Queen's
connection ok what can you do he took it
what else and now he simply played
bishop takes
rakh beautiful now black look at the
position he said wait a minute
I was planning on taking back that
bishop at least but I don't think I can
do that because you didn't do it let me
show you had he taken here then white
would have played Queen whoopsie
Queen takes b6 check if the King goes to
e8 the rook is gonna take the bishop
with check and then do the same thing
and if the King goes to d7 you can
imagine that after rook c7 check doesn't
look good for the black player right
looks really yucky yep so after the
takes he played Bishop d7 and again
morphic can just take the pawn on b6 we
check of course then save his bishop but
again he plays kind of a fancy move
maybe to show his opponent that even
though he's not looking at the board he
can still see tricks like this and watch
what he did Bishop b5 instead of
capturing something he is giving him a
gift and not a bishop but this is a very
bad gift to take he realized that if he
takes it which he didn't then Queen
takes b6 check and the poor King has to
go right into the line of fire where I'm
gonna take this bishop with a check or
again I have rook check and rook check
why just wins material what a disaster
so he played King to e8 and more if he
played the not a brilliant move pawn
takes pawn still ignoring his bishop to
think that he didn't even look at this
board when he was playing this game and
that was not even his only game there
were other games and he sees everything
almost like he was looking at the board
but he wasn't now of course the ideas if
the bishop takes the bishop on b5 rook
c8 jack and the poor Queen has to block
that check that'll be the only legal
move Wow
so Knight f6 he said okay I have to give
you some material a giving material just
leave me alone and Murphy played rook to
see a check
taking care of the fact that the bishop
is pinned and in this position our
cunningham just said you know what i
resign
enough is enough after the said move
Queen to d8 he would play pawn takes
pawn bishop check thank you very much
the King has to move then I can take the
Queen well when you count the material
you see that white ends up with a ton of
extra material that's not fun to play
and black resigned
did you understand this game cool now
before you get to play a little bit and
you will I'm always always in all my
lectures especially the ones that are
recorded I always like to finish them
with a little bit of a funny position to
show so let me show it to you this is a
very cute composition that I like to
show to my students it's again it's not
really regular chess it's like a
composition obviously although this is a
legal position somebody can have a door
for a bishop right and then promote
these bones and make more bishops just
for fun and when you look at the
position you think yourself okay White
has five bishops which is a lot of
points but probably can't win right
because the white kid the black King is
on a light square and how are you ever
going to move me away
I'm never gonna move away from the light
square well that could be I am just
gonna run around the light squares if
you take the space away from me it's
gonna be stalemate well that is kind of
true but notice that black has a little
pawn right here so he will never really
be stalemated he'll always have move
with the pawn and that one is also going
to harm him at some point so this is why
to move in win and I'm going to show you
the solution because trying to figure
out is really difficult
so look white plays here and black has
two moves
he can play between 85 and King a 2 if
you would have played let's say King a
to King C 2 the king is kind of
stalemated right so push bishop a1 push
bishop move push King to c3
now you can take the bishop or go clean
be one doesn't matter let's say you take
the bishop King to be three here bishop
a one only legal move is a to King c3
what is your only bigger move has to
take the bishop and then King c2 is
checkmate
exactly exactly so let's go back to that
position before we had King a to here if
a five first then Bishop a one again the
same idea a four here here here just
waiting a two and then King c3 and of
course after King a one King C to
checkmate
so King and five bishops of the same
color against King and pawn when the
king is trapped in the corner is it when
but this is again not really real chess
just kind of Funches okay guys thank you
very much for listening and now we get
to play a little bit because I was told
that you guys really want to play each
other so I have to abide by that so
please find yourself opponents and play